one year ago an attempted coup in Turkey
fail it's still not clear exactly what
happened who was behind it
president air duan blames Fethullah
Gulen a us-based Islamic cleric and an
ally turned critic but the evidence air
Dhawan is offered in support of his
extradition has been shortened through
there's other suspects officers upset by
air dhawan and who secularised meaning
hidemoto air Dhawan himself once quipped
my goals raised in Islamic generation or
it could have been a Reichstag fire type
plot to justify a crackdown air tawan
called the attempt to get some God my
own series all of the above
Erewhon may have discovered the plot
early but allowed us to continue to
justify the crackdown what's certain is
this Turkey today is a dictatorship it's
anti us
anti Europe and pro-russia it's the most
anti NATO NATO member what we're
witnessing now however is a sprint to
erase Ataturk's legacy and replaced
Turkey with an Islamic state by 2023 the
hundredth anniversary of turkey's
independence we've been covering Turkey
a lot at AEI check out our work is wwii
org or let us know your thoughts in the
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars cover in
60 seconds and be sure to subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI